NARRATOR: Egypt,
the richest source of
archaeological
treasures on the planet.
WOMAN: Oh,
that's a fabulous one.
NARRATOR: Beneath this desert
landscape lie the secrets
of this ancient civilization.
JOHN: Wow, can you see why the
Pharaoh's chose this place?
NARRATOR: Now for a
full season of excavations,
our cameras have been given
unprecedented access
to follow teams on the
frontline of archaeology.
MAN: I'm driving so fast
because I'm so excited!
WOMAN: It's an entrance,
we can see an entrance!
NARRATOR: Revealing
buried secrets.
MAN: I have just
been told that they
have found something.
Oh my gosh!
JOHN: A sphinx!
NARRATOR: And making
discoveries that could
rewrite ancient history.
This time, new secrets of
the boy king, Tutankhamun.
Alia uses pioneering
technology to reveal startling
new evidence about his tomb,
and why it remained
hidden for 3,000 years.
ALIAA: A lot of
robberies were going on,
how was it not found?
NARRATOR: Eissa's team
discovers a long-lost cache of
King Tutankhamun's treasures.
NARRATOR: And Alejandro
discovers extraordinary
burial treasures in a
4,000 year-old tomb.
ALEJANDRO: Congratulations!
NARRATOR: The Valley of
the Kings, 3,500 years ago,
the Great Pharaohs
stopped building
pyramids as their tombs.
They chose these
secluded cliffs to
become their cemetery.
Today, archaeologists come
from all over the world to
unlock the mysteries still
hidden in this
City of the Dead.
It's the first
day in the Valley for
Cairo born Egyptologist
Aliaa Ismail and her team.
ALIAA: There's a real
buzz in this place.
People are coming from
all over the world, coming
to the Valley, it's amazing.
I'm so proud to
have such ancestry.
It's one of the most
famous necropolises in
the world and I think what
is special is that
it comes out of nowhere.
NARRATOR: Over
300 miles south of Cairo,
in the heart of Egypt,
lie the limestone cliffs
of the Valley of the Kings.
After 200 years of excavation,
archaeologists have
located sixty-five tombs
hidden among the rocks.
But only one has
ever been found with
its treasure still inside,
it belonged to the
Pharaoh, Tutankhamun.
ALIAA: This here is
number 62, Tutankhamun.
One of those great
finds of the century.
NARRATOR: British
explorer Howard Carter
discovered Tutankhamun's
tomb in 1922.
One of his teams
spotted steps leading
down through the sand.
They led to the tomb
entrance, buried beneath
feet of rubble and debris.
What Carter found inside
inspired archaeologists
for generations to come.
Deep inside the mountains,
amid a maze of tunnels that
bore deep through the rock,
Carter reached the tomb
of Tutankhamun hidden right
in the center of the Valley.
Inside, he found
treasures unlike anything
ever seen before.
Over 5,000 priceless artifacts
including golden statues.
In the burial
chamber the Pharaoh's mummy,
wearing a golden death mask,
was placed inside
a coffin made of more than
200 pounds of solid gold.
This intact tomb made
Tutankhamun the most
famous of the Pharaohs.
Now Aliaa is investing
this golden Pharaoh's life.
ALIAA: Wow.
NARRATOR: And why his tomb
remained hidden for so long.
Aliaa's team has been
scanning and documenting the
tomb for the last ten years,
and they've made a
remarkable discovery.
ALIAA: The idea here
is to understand what's
going on when you look at
the data void of color.
NARRATOR: The scans strip
away the paint on the walls
to reveal unusual markings.
ALIAA: This was the main
scene, and here is the
3D of the North Wall.
So, as you can see here,
the silhouette of an
image and this would have
been done while
they were painting.
NARRATOR: The images
show the indented outline
of the face hidden below.
It's caused by the
tip of the paintbrush if
you start painting when
the plaster is still wet.
ALIAA: This is why the
brushes would have made a
very light impression and
this allows us to
understand it was rushed.
NARRATOR: But why would
the tomb builders rush
such an important job?
The pictures on the wall
reveal another set of clues.
Despite becoming the
most famous Pharaoh
of Ancient Egypt,
Tutankhamun did
not have a lengthy reign.
He was only
a nine-year-old boy
when he became King,
and relied on
trusted advisors to help
rule his vast empire.
As Tutankhamun grew older,
he was known to portray
himself as a warrior king,
riding into battle
on a chariot.
But the boy King suffered
from multiple illnesses,
including Malaria.
He was only
nineteen-years-old when
he unexpectantly died.
(speaking in Arabic).
NARRATOR: Aliaa thinks
the marks her scans reveal
in the plaster are evidence
of a hurried burial due to
Tutankhamun's sudden death.
ALIAA: The decorated part
of the tomb is very small,
it's only the burial chamber.
The rest of the tomb
is not decorated.
If they had more
time, all of this was
going to be decorated.
NARRATOR: While the tomb's
construction may have been
rushed, its treasures were
everything a Pharaoh
could desire to take
him into the afterlife.
So why did this tomb lay
hidden below a layer of rock
for thousands of years when
all the other tombs in
the Valley were looted?
To solve this mystery,
Aliaa will turn to new
technology as she moves her
investigation out
into the Valley.
300 miles north, in Giza,
in the shadow of the
pyramids, the biggest
treasure haul in history
is getting a new home, a
one-billion-dollar museum
and research center.
When completed, the Grand
Egyptian Museum will reunite
all of Tutankhamun's treasures
in one place, for the
first time in 100 years.
TAREK: Having all of
the pieces from the tomb
of Tutankhamun together
in one place, this will
be a fantastic chance
to find new facts,
new hidden things
about Tutankhamun.
NARRATOR: After Carter
removed the treasures
from Tut's tomb,
they ended up
in museums around Egypt.
Now, for the first time,
scientists and Egyptologists
will use modern
technology to
analyze each object.
TAREK: Some details reappear
and give us new information
about these antiquities.
NARRATOR: But some
of Tut's greatest
treasures are yet to arrive.
300 miles south in the
Luxor Museum, Eissa Zidan
is preparing 122 of these
priceless artifacts
for the move to Giza.
NARRATOR: Eissa's
packing list includes one
of Tut's famous chariots,
intricate model boats and
a unique head
of the cow Goddess, Hathor,
elaborately gilded with gold.
(speaking in Arabic).
NARRATOR: After just four
hours, Eissa's packing
suddenly comes to a halt.
One of his teams has
discovered something
completely unexpected
in the storeroom.
It's an antique box that
Howard Carter used to pack
and transport Tutankhamun's
treasures out of the tomb.
NARRATOR: The box
has been missing,
presumed lost, for decades,
and no one knows what
treasures it may hold.
120 miles south of the Valley
of the Kings, near Aswan,
a Spanish Research
Team from Jaen University
is hoping to follow in
Carter's footsteps and make new
discoveries that
could rewrite history.
(speaking in Arabic).
Professor
Alejandro Jimenez-Serrano
heads the largest foreign team
working in Egypt.
Today is the first
day of the dig season.
ALEJANDRO: Sorry for the mess.
We are sharing the room,
three researchers of the team.
This is my, my bed,
supposedly the best one.
(laughs).
Sorry.
(coughs).
It's amazing to get up
and the first thing that you
see apart from the ugly face
of your roommates is the
Qubbet el-Hawa, the hill.
NARRATOR: Qubbet el-Hawa
is one of the largest ancient
burial sites in Egypt.
So far, 100 tombs
have been discovered here.
They belong to the
nobles who governed Egypt
hundreds of years before
the Pharaoh's buried in
the Valley of the Kings.
(speaking in Arabic).
Alejandro's mission is
to hunt for more unopened
tombs and reveal more
about these early Egyptians.
ALEJANDRO: It's difficult
to explain how I feel.
Not only nervous,
it's exciting, it's
a mix of feelings.
It's an honor to...
to come every year.
Now here comes the most
difficult part of the day,
to climb the hill.
NARRATOR: This is the
team's tenth year digging here.
WOMAN: It's so nice
to be here again.
(laughs).
NARRATOR: There's
a reason why everyone
is excited to be back.
Last year, Alejandro
found the entranced
to a sealed tomb,
but his permit
expired before he
could explore inside.
ALEJANDRO: Today
is 40 degrees, and
working underneath the sun,
today's gonna be tough.
NARRATOR: To protect against
modern day tomb-robbers,
they put a steel security
door to block the entrance
of the vertical
shaft that leads to the
sealed burial chamber.
ALEJANDRO: Well it has been
one-year waiting, one-year
imagining the possibilities.
I'm very excited.
NARRATOR: In Luxor, Eissa's
team packs Tutankhamun's
treasures for the move
to the Grand Egyptian
Museum in Giza.
But in the storeroom,
Eissa is ready to open
Carter's long-lost
box to discover
what's inside.
NARRATOR: The team gathers
around to see if the box
really does contain priceless
treasures from
Tutankhamun's tomb.
MOHAMMAD: Ah.
(laughter)
MAN: Fantastic.
MOHAMMAD: It's amazing.
NARRATOR: These
delicate wooden pieces
are ancient boat parts.
NARRATOR: Storeroom
records suggest they could
be missing from a model boat
Howard Carter
found in Tutankhamun's tomb.
NARRATOR: According to
ancient Egyptian belief,
boats played a
key role after death.
So, placing model boats
into tombs was a vital
part of any burial.
The vessels also came
complete with crew because
it was believed the replicas
would come to life
and help with fishing and
transport in the underworld.
The Pharaohs used a
special vessel to sail
across the sky for eternity.
Ordinary people also
thought they could reach
the afterlife by boat,
rowing on the Nile
and into the next world.
MOHAMMAD: You can see here
the date of the newspaper,
it's Sunday 5th
of November, 1933.
NARRATOR: To discover
where these pieces came from,
Mohammad inspects
Carter's original inventory.
NARRATOR: Records
show that the box was
sent to Luxor in 1973
but had gone missing,
presumed lost or stolen.
NARRATOR: Eissa thinks
the rest of the boat is
safe in the new Cairo lab,
so they may finally
be able to reunite it.
To transport
the treasures to Giza,
Eissa's team must
traverse 400 miles
of barren desert roads
and crowded city streets
before they reach the
safety of the new museum.
It will take two trucks
to transport all 122 of
the artifacts to Giza.
EISSA: This a very,
very big moment
for the collection,
this is the final
trip of Tutankhamun.
NARRATOR: But with such
priceless relics on board,
there's concern
the convoy could be a
target for a hijacking.
EISSA: We have a good
police and good army.
They will follow us
during moving from Luxor
until arrive to Cairo.
NARRATOR: With security
in place, it's time to roll.
They now face a
grueling twelve-hour journey
through the desert to
reach Giza before nightfall.
Ever since Carter's
discovery of Tutankhamun's
priceless golden treasures,
archaeologists have
continued to try and figure
out where and how the
ancient Egyptians found
vast quantities of gold.
Fifty-miles south
of the Valley of the Kings,
on the edge of
the Eastern Desert,
French gold expert
Thomas Faucher and
archaeologist John Ward are
on the hunt for the origins
of Tutankhamun's gold.
THOMAS: So, I'm going to...
JOHN: What are you
waiting for, a traffic signal?
NARRATOR: The Eastern Desert
covers 85,000 square-miles
of remote barren wilderness.
Some of the rock here
contains tiny grains
of gold locked inside.
Thomas has studied ancient
gold mining techniques
for seven years.
Now he wants to see if he
can find any evidence of it.
But this part of the desert
is a risky place to be.
THOMAS: The thing is we
need to leave before dark
because it's not safe if we are
staying there because
we can lose our way,
we can have an accident and
it's also at
the sunset that all the
snakes are going out.
JOHN: Snakes?
THOMAS: Yeah, vipers.
JOHN: No one told me about...
THOMAS: There are
horrid vipers, yeah.
NARRATOR: The first
stop, an ancient well.
It could provide
clues to the location
of mining communities during
the time of Tutankhamun.
THOMAS: This is the well just
right in front of us here.
JOHN: It's dry.
My God, that's
a long way down.
NARRATOR: The well
might be dry today,
but it was so important to
the ancient
Egyptians, they built
a temple to honor it.
JOHN: It's beautiful isn't it?
They actually applied
a plaster gyp ceiling and
then applied the paint.
Amazing.
NARRATOR: The text
engraved on these walls
reveals clues about the
gold miners and
where they were heading.
Ancient engineers built
a network of wells and rest
stops stretching all the way
across the desert, each
a day's walk from the last,
enabling travelers and miners
to safely cross and
explore the barren desert.
The temple carvings
indicate these wells
led toward the mines.
Thomas hopes he
will be able to find some
evidence of the people
behind Tutankhamun's
goldmining operations.
THOMAS: Now it's time
to go deeper East...
NARRATOR: Like an
ancient treasure map,
they must follow the trail of
wells further into the desert.
In Aswan, at the ancient
burial site of Qubbet el-Hawa,
Alejandro is about to
open a 4,000-year-old tomb.
They're on the hunt
for whatever burial
treasure may be inside.
ALEJANDRO:
I don't know who is more
nervous, me or my team.
I want to go now!
(laughs).
NARRATOR: After a year
of waiting, Alejandro can
finally enter the tomb.
ALEJANDRO: It's amazing.
NARRATOR: It contains a
4,000-year-old coffin.
Workers have inserted
a box covered in acid-free
paper inside the coffin to
stop it from collapsing
while they examine the tomb.
(sighs).
ALEJANDRO: There, we
have been very lucky.
It's impossible to explain
the feelings that I'm having.
The burial consisted in two
coffins, the outer coffin
and the inner coffin.
NARRATOR: Among the
debris of the outer coffin,
Alejandro spots
something extraordinary.
ALEJANDRO: It is full
of wooden models, but
unfortunately, the outer
coffin fall over them.
NARRATOR: The chamber
is full of model boats,
similar to the one
in Tutankhamun's tomb.
ALEJANDRO: To find
this funerary boat in
a tomb is rare today.
NARRATOR: But there's
not just one, there are
four, complete with crew.
ALEJANDRO: You want
to laugh, you want to
shout, you want to cry.
NARRATOR: This is the
first time in seventy-years
a set of boats like
this has been found.
This discovery gives
Alejandro an extremely
rare opportunity to study
such important burial goods.
But first he has to extract
them from the tomb safely.
Alejandro calls in his team
of conservation specialists,
Sara and Theresa.
NARRATOR: Termites have
attacked the wooden boats.
Sara sprays on a
liquid adhesive to
hold them together.
ALEJANDRO: So, we
will see if they are
capable to make a miracle.
NARRATOR: They prepare
a foam-lined cradle to
support the boat for the move
to the team's restoration lab,
but the wooden hull is
stuck to the tomb floor.
It'll require surgical
precision using
scalpels to free it.
ALEJANDRO: From the
tomb to the restoration
lab we are talking
about perhaps 40-meters.
But today's very windy which
is very, very aggressive.
NARRATOR: The ancient
boats are extremely fragile.
ALEJANDRO: Get ready.
NARRATOR: With a drop in the
wind, the team sees the chance
to remove the first boat.
♪ ♪
ALEJANDRO: Perfect.
That was exciting.
One of the best
moments in my career.
WOMAN: We have 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 8 person.
ALEJANDRO: We take
many weeks to clean it and
fix the pieces that were
broken some centuries ago.
NARRATOR: While the team
gets to work on the boat,
Alejandro can finally
open the coffin to see
who and what is inside.
In the middle of the desert,
the convoy carrying
Tutankhamun's priceless
treasures is two hours
into its journey when
Eissa spots a problem.
NARRATOR: A thermal blanket
protecting Tut's golden
chariot is coming loose.
If it flies off, it
could cause a crash.
NARRATOR: The unscheduled
stop in the desert makes
this convoy,
carrying the world's
most priceless treasures, a
potential target for hijackers.
(speaking in Arabic).
NARRATOR: Eissa and his
team are unable to secure
the loose thermal covering
protecting Tut's chariot.
NARRATOR: Removing the cover,
they risk the
scorching desert heat
potentially damaging
the priceless treasure.
EISSA: Everything is okay.
NARRATOR: Now, Eissa needs
to get the convoy moving.
HASSAN: We hope to
arrive to Cairo safely.
NARRATOR: In the Valley,
Egyptologist Aliaa
Ismail is on a mission to
discover how Tutankhamun's
tomb and treasures remained
hidden for 3,000 years.
ALIAA: A lot of robberies
were going on in ancient
times and modern times.
But it seems that this
particular tomb was not found.
How was it not found?
NARRATOR: The ancient
engineers of Tutankhamun's
tomb had a plan.
Inside the mountain,
they went to great lengths
to conceal the tomb.
The Pharaoh's
burial chamber is located
26 feet underground,
and is defended
from the inside out.
Engineers constructed
a wall to block off
the burial chamber.
They filled the
corridor leading to the
King with tons of rubble,
before sealing a
final doorway and covering
Tutankhamun's tomb with
a vast amount of boulders
under earth standard
tomb protection of the day.
But when Carter
discovered this tomb, it had
more material on top than
any other in the Valley.
This may explain how it
remained undiscovered
for over 3,000 years.
But how did this extra
rock and debris get here?
Aliaa joins German Geologist
Martin Ziegler to investigate.
MARTIN: If you want to
understand the evolution of
the Valley of the Kings, you
need to also understand
the evolution of the rock.
NARRATOR: Martin
thinks there could be clues
in the rocks at the
entrance to a nearby tomb.
MARTIN: Just at the
entrance of it, a slab
is just hanging above,
a rock basically could
fall out of the cliff.
NARRATOR: Egypt
is hit with dozens of
earthquakes each year.
So, Martin's
installed a seismometer to
measure any vibrations that
could trigger rock falls.
MARTIN: With this one
we calculate it to be...
weigh about 600 to 700
kilometers from the
Valley of the Kings.
ALIAA: What if an
earthquake would...
were to happen like much
closer to the Valley of the
Kings, how would it affect it?
MARTIN: A very big
earthquake could destabilize
some rock portions.
So, when you look in the...
in the history of recorded
earthquakes, the historic
timescales, let's say the
thousands of years, we have
some records of earthquakes
of that type of magnitude.
NARRATOR: So, could rock
falls caused by earthquakes
3,000 years ago account
for the extra tons of
rock that covered the
entrance to Tutankhamun's tomb?
MARTIN: From the geological
past and the historic point
of view, they could have rock
falls or rock slides
that are triggered by
earthquakes covering tombs.
NARRATOR: But there are
no cliffs directly above
Tutankhamun's tomb, so it
wouldn't have been hit
by a direct rockfall.
How did so much extra
material travel down the
valley and completely cover
the entrance to the tomb?
To solve this mystery
Aliaa and Martin
must take to the air.
Deep in the Eastern Desert,
Thomas and John are looking
for evidence of the miners who
produced the gold for
Tutankhamun's treasures.
They're trying to find
a route of ancient wells
that the goldminers would
have followed as they
travelled to the mines.
JOHN: It's like looking
for a needle in a haystack.
But I'm losing a few kidneys.
(laughs).
NARRATOR: Seventy miles
from the last ancient well,
Thomas and John
head into the unknown.
With their G-P-S broken
down, they now risk
getting completely lost.
JOHN: This piece of
technology is defunct!
It is not working.
Look here, it's literally
on the right side.
So, we are now
at the back end.
So, we need to turn around.
NARRATOR: But after
two days of searching,
John thinks they may have
finally found something.
JOHN: What's that over there?
At the base of that
mountain there?
So, we found it!
THOMAS: Okay, so it looks
that we've found a very
interesting place here.
It's a settlement.
NARRATOR: It may look like
scattered stones and debris,
but to Thomas' expert eye,
he can see the outline
of ancient buildings.
THOMAS: We have the huts
where the people were living
and where they were working.
Yeah, we definitely have
here the evidence...
JOHN: Oh Thomas...
THOMAS: Here...
I mean people
have been working
here and we see, yeah,
there are even more over there.
NARRATOR: As they get closer,
John spots the tools
the ancient miners
would have used to extract
gold from the rocks.
JOHN: Oh.
THOMAS: Yeah, that's
the grinding stone.
JOHN: That's a pounder.
THOMAS: Yeah,
that's a pounder.
Yeah, exactly.
JOHN: That's what
they would break...
THOMAS: Yeah they would...
JOHN: The quartz with.
THOMAS: Yeah.
NARRATOR: It's the remains of
an ancient goldmining camp.
JOHN: I mean how many people
are we talking, 20, 30?
THOMAS: Yeah maybe there were
like families living here.
NARRATOR: Thomas has
studied ancient mining
techniques for years.
But seeing this evidence
first-hand brings home the
hardships the miners endured.
THOMAS: You start from
a piece of quartz like
this and you want to make
product out of it.
So, you need to crush it.
And you have to imagine
how much pain it takes just
to break a
single piece of quartz,
doing that like all
day long, in the sun,
pounding and pounding and
grinding and grinding
and doing that for years.
NARRATOR: Evidence here
paints a picture of the
life of desert miners.
They cut shafts stretching
up to thirty-two feet deep
into the stone in search of
precious seams of quartz
rock that contained gold.
Crushing the quartz was
a massive undertaking.
Mining experts have
calculated that a team
of twenty people would take
a week to process
enough stone to make
just a spoonful of gold.
THOMAS: That's heavy.
JOHN: Seriously.
NARRATOR: Sadly, there is
very little evidence left of
these ancient mines, but these
settlements provide new
insight into the communities
that lived such hard lives
processing the gold.
THOMAS: We have all the
material they were using
for sure, that they were
working here to extract and
process the gold to send it
to the Valley of the Kings.
JOHN: We've found it.
THOMAS: We've found it.
NARRATOR: In Aswan,
Alejandro's team prepares to
remove the coffin from the
tomb they've opened.
Inscriptions reveal it belongs
to a man called Shemai.
ALEJANDRO: They have
just struck the lid of
the coffin of Shemai.
Rebecca, you are the first
person that is looking at
Shemai's face in 4000 years.
(speaking in Arabic).
Congratulations!
(laughs).
NARRATOR: The inner
coffin is intact, but
extremely fragile.
Alejandro's team has
reinforced it to try and
protect the mummy inside.
ALEJANDRO: It's
difficult to express the
feelings that I have now.
It's a special moment because
I'm studying this family, and
it's almost my second family.
NARRATOR: In the
restoration lab,
the intricate beauty
of the model boats
is starting to appear.
Termites have
eaten much of the wood,
but their excrement
has actually helped hold
parts of the boats together
for thousands of years.
ALEJANDRO: We have some
parts that are still in a very
good state of conservation.
This head of the man,
it is covered with
excrement of the termites,
but the wood is still visible.
NARRATOR: Alejandro has
spotted a figure distinct
from the other carvings.
ALEJANDRO: We can see in the
middle of the boat a yellow
face which belongs to a mummy,
which would represent Shemai.
NARRATOR: This exceptional
discovery will help
archaeologists understand
the evolution of burial
practices in ancient Egypt.
ALEJANDRO: I was
dreaming always to
discover something like this,
and it's a dream that came true.
NARRATOR: Alejandro's
next task is to bring
Shemai's mummy above ground
for the first time
in 4,000 years.
NARRATOR: In the
Valley of the Kings,
Aliaa and Martin look
for clues to explain why
Tutankhamun's tomb
remained hidden for so long.
They've got special
permission from the Government
to use a drone to get a unique
perspective on the position
of Tutankhamun's tomb.
MARTIN: There we go.
MAN: If we look down we
should be over the Tutankhamun
entrance right now.
MARTIN: Now we can see the
cliffs in the back, and we can
see the central position of
the tomb.
And above we can see debris.
NARRATOR: Loose rock and
debris cover the cliffs
behind Tut's tomb.
But the drone also reveals
these flood channels, carved
into the rock by heavy rains
over thousands of
years and they could be
the vital missing clue.
MARTIN: We think that if we
have flash flooding, that
material can flow down in
these kinds of channels.
NARRATOR: Throughout
history the Valley has
been hit by earthquakes,
and occasional flash floods.
The flood waters push rubble
downhill toward the tombs.
Tutankhamun's tomb
lies in the spot where the
channels of water converge,
and dump tons of rock.
This, combined with stone
chippings from a tomb built
above, buried the entrance
deeper and kept it hidden
for over 3,000 years.
ALIAA: It's very exciting
for me as an Egyptologist
to see Tutankhamun's tomb
from up here and see how it
fits within the valley.
It is the prime
location, it is the one
that was most protected.
He got the most
sheltered tomb of all.
NARRATOR: Tutankhamun was
a boy King who played a
minor role in Egypt's history,
but because his
tomb remained hidden
for thousands of years,
his treasure was kept
safe from robbers and
made him
the legend we know today.
In Aswan, the team is
bringing the mummy of
ancient Egyptian Shemai
to the surface for the
first time in 4,000 years.
This is the culmination
of ten years of field
work for Alejandro,
and an incredible
opportunity to
learn more about Shemai.
ALEJANDRO: Oh 125,
it's quite short.
My daughter is more
of less like this and
she's eight years old.
I expected that at
least he would be around
20-years-old or something.
It has been a surprise.
I never expected that
he could be just a boy.
On his coffin it
was written that he was
the person in charge of
the administration of the store.
Controlling the store,
you control the people
because you decide who is going
to receive food or not.
NARRATOR: This new
evidence reveals Shemai
held a powerful position in
Egyptian Society at
a very young age.
He may not have been
a Pharaoh, but like
the boy King Tutankhamun,
his status afforded him a tomb
and burial goods to ensure a
safe passage into the afterlif.
It's taken twelve
hours, but finally
Eissa and his convoy of
Tutankhamun's treasures
arrive in the city.
It's very, very,
very exciting.
We wait for this moment.
NARRATOR: Tarek Tawfik
the Museum Director,
is anxious to get
everything safely inside.
TAREK: The first cradles
have to be taken out, in
order for the Tutankhamun
pieces to start emerging.
EISSA: Now I can say
I'm very, very happy.
Mission is complete, yes.
TAREK: It will be like
unpacking Christmas presents.
When we get out these pieces
and find out more details
about how they complement the
whole story of
King Tutankhamun.
NARRATOR: Eissa's team
can finally unpack the
priceless treasures.
Scientists and
Egyptologists can
now begin to study and
analyze each item in
their new high-tech lab.
Top of the list are the
newly discovered boat pieces.
MOHAMMAD: We'll check
now in our database which
of them maybe related to any
of the boats in the storeroom.
NARRATOR: For almost
100 years, the boat that was
buried alongside Tutankhamun
to help him travel
into the afterlife has
been missing its mast.
(speaking in Arabic).
HASSAN: Exactly!
MOHAMMAD: It's very beautiful.
It's amazing that after all
these years, we still have new
discoveries and new secrets
for this golden King,
Tutankhamun.
NARRATOR: 100 years
after its discovery,
Tutankhamun's stunning
treasure is still
surprising the world.
And the Valley of the Kings
shows why it remains the
greatest place on Earth to
hunt for the secrets of
Egypt's famous Pharaohs.
Captioned by Cotter
Captioning Services.